ah
we're gonna take every flavor of cake
mix and we're gonna make it into one
giant cake you're dr. Franklin cake and
the cake is called Franklin cakes cake
Thanks
sixteen frostings baby we got some
interesting flavors we got some carrot
mm-hmm got some spice angel food we have
to take the big bowls and put a little
bit of all 18 yeah a few of them and
then we put we fill up these and we're
gonna like stack them and it's gonna be
a giant six layer Franken cake I'm gonna
start with funfetti my fav yeah that's a
bummer I can't like test any of the raw
batter still when she's not looking you
know red velvet done as much as I want
this to taste good
I'm gonna put some lemon in this lemon
taste good all the time score two lemons
you know we're at six right there to the
way there oh it's like melting it oh oh
now we're solution now we're swirling
that looks nice that's beautiful
that foam is just mmm I know it's really
like bubbling give me a sitcom Kay two
cakes again no 310 mixes down eight more
to go
I'm with rolling this packet of carrot
and raisins into the mix don't I have to
do some weird stuff I need to get hot
water and put my carrots and raisins
into it
oh god I'm losing steam don't worry I'm
just freaking out just freaking out no
big deal
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa delicious whoa boom boys whatever
yeah said that right no don't step on
that okay making cake or
seven hours yeah we made cake Amanda
actually smells pretty good
now we're gonna stack stack these and
frost them it's gonna make things look
much prettier than they are currently
let's cover this up right away oh great
it's beautiful they start consistent
with burning it on the sides as much as
this cake has hurt me feel a little bit
bad Wow look at this this is amazing
get some lemon in there join the party
lemon this is becoming an art piece oh
my god Oh
[Music]
really very good very unique flavor
cinnamony fritters
butter apple banana peanut butter good
taste wise I would say ten out of ten
looks wise
[Music]